we've tried the chicken factory I'm
still having nightmares about those
giblets we try beautician hot wax is not
my friend I'm running out of options for
you here Luiza please I'll take anything
this is New York air and companionship
for disabled man do you have any
experience of caregiving I've never done
it but I'm sure I could learn then
that's gonna do well well this is new
music lock Nathan we'll talk you through
world's routines and equipment you don't
have to talk cross me mother my brain
isn't paralyzed yep thank you we're
quite used to seeing you in quite sort
of physical roles like in The Hunger
Games was this raw would you say almost
harder to prepare for because it's so
kind of emotionally demanding and
intense in its storyline yeah I mean I
think physically as well it was the most
amount of training I've ever done
building up to a part there was a very
strict diet and a very very very strict
sort of exercise exercise regime that I
was doing purely to sort of shed muscle
mass and look as sort of weak and tired
especially when we first meet him
post-accident leo we want to kind of
really make him not look in a good place
so yeah there was a really really tough
physical journey I went on but also of
course mentally and emotionally it was
draining it was really really draining I
think I've never cared so much for a
project and a part and you know a story
that it really really sort of took me to
a very very dark place yeah and one of
the things I found kind of most powerful
about the film it's actually the
relationship between Will and his
parents yes that kind of do you find the
story resonates with you even more in
that way now that you're a parent
yourself no I mean I think I think
you're right for me it was I was you
know when we were filming this I was
very very much a part of it and I think
especially when you go back to the
source material the relationship between
his parents and him is very very odd not
odds but it's complicated and come
and him doing what he does at the end of
the movie is is him kite is a release
for him it's a very selfless act that he
wants to basically allow them to live
their lives without having to focus and
worry about him because he's very proud
and he wants to you know rid people of
complications so for me that that was
definitely one of my favorite
relationships to explore and to have I
mean the two of them my apartment that
is like a dream I know I should
definitely be six for something because
never at all but yeah now I'm a parent
is definitely I suppose something a new
aspect of film that I've started
exploring yeah and a couple of years ago
you a glamorous man of the year yes I'm
who would if you could pick anyone who
would be your man of the year I'm going
to say Eddie Redmayne just because he's
very good friend and somebody who I
think I've always aspired to be like he
was on my first of a job and I think
watching him grow especially now as an
actor and with each job that he does and
each decision that he makes really is
quite inspiring to me so I'm not sure
whether he's already been a man of the
year he may already he really needs to
be yeah and including this film you've
done you've taken a lot of roles that
have come from books first
is there any there any roles from books
that would be a dream for you yes there
is there is a book that I I love which I
think everyone should read it's called
the art of racing in the rain it's a
story about a man and his dog and what
family life but told through a dog's
eyes and it's really quite a magical
book I think it's my favorite book and
yeah there's a part of you know the man
is definitely something I'd like to do
but whether or not that you know how
that works I have no idea but I'm
honestly not a huge reader I don't I
don't I've been fortunate enough each
job that I do seems to be based on a
novel so I kind of read my work that
made
since I'm kind of I feel like I'm behind
I need to kind of yeah catch up amazing
thank you very much I don't want you to
miss all the things that someone else
can give you
I have become a whole new person because
of you there's something called you up
pretty much here anything that makes me
want to get up in the morning wait for
me to come home